Je m'appelle Rodrigo Díaz, je suis né à Vivar.
mon père est mort en combattant pour fernando
premier de tout héritage il m'en a laissé un
épée
quand il a été conçu
nous partageons la baixa avec les rois princes et
nobles nous commençons la bataille à vos côtés
on se bat avec eux on meurt avec eux
ni toi ni moi ne sommes comme l'un d'eux
une révolte se prépare contre lui
usurper de sa vie un danger
ils ont essayé de tuer pendant la joute
les soupçons des soupçons de tout le monde avec ça
animal que j'admire tant
[Musique]
le trône durerait une seconde entre les mains de
une femme
tu ne m'as pas oublié
Dieu a marqué un destin à être
choses qu'aucun homme ne peut faire
gloire d'attente
[Applaudissements]
sur le terrain est à nous
l'histoire du terrain
le campeur
[Musique]